hello and welcome to this video we have
the number of mistakes lads okay and
then play a Petrov I don't get it
get a four nights but with Bishop c4
taking here is oh you would think that
you don't get this kind of thing anymore
that is so well known that white is in
terrible shape iam like it gets tons of
Tempe and this is also quite an
annoyance g2 was attacked
I wonder though like III know doesn't do
it okay
by the way I have adjusted the search
algorithm here for the search algorithm
sounds wrong um the search criteria for
the opponent's going with 2200 plus but
sometimes you simply don't get an
opponent with those with this criteria
so if I wait too long I'm going to go
down to 2,000 or without anything like
here I wondered about 91 it could you
know it looked a bit of awkward okay
here I'm threatening rook e8 maybe I
should have checked the first no he can
make a not really cancel here 94 okay
let's see let's him what he does okay
here check would you love to sacrifice
then only three but it does not really
work unfortunately
okay the check is good though I mean the
rook is fine on the e-file and I'm also
happy if I can trade here okay
the night is of course completely wrong
on on the square I wondered is he going
for a long castle in here maybe
okay let's that's here and that he
doesn't it doesn't do that
you know it's tough to not play b3 now
even though b3 looks very shaky actually
b3 I can take III okay so now young
Knights if one looks correct it is going
to play Queen to d3 so what is the right
way to do this here
[Music]
may hold on f3 is actually slightly in
danger that that is playtest like really
badly really badly
that was absolutely terrible what I did
now the five is hanging f3 is under
pressure I mean I was winning I was
winning out by the baton with 10 and now
I'm in this nonsense this is absolutely
terrible really ok I was more afraid he
would takes his salmon
this is still good I think I mean not as
good as it should have been but still
have some hope that I could win this
game okay let's take that file
[Music]
really really awful
age three was I think helpful for me I
don't see how it's not using the Jeep
arm now
okay I cannot really keep the bonds he's
got you can check me for him
[Music]
like a group here I go into f6 and give
him that my my pawns are further
advanced that is more porn than the porn
count I think
huh nein what am I doing here
ah I'm what don't tell me I'm blonde at
f3m my god
what a game
- really unbelievable nonsense here what
I'm doing
we're still winning I think I'm
promoting him wait
and so I wanted but that is a deeply
annoying game em I mean this is this is
a position where you should actually
just win I mean it shouldn't really be a
game Blanc is completely in control and
shouldn't be like 20 moves okay
Queen g5 isn't even best him okay it's
okay I'm okay with what I did here and
now I went Bishop f3 this is already
terrible I think because it can take it
and play Knight you won and I mean I I
thought okay maybe I can play 94 and
yeah it is better for black yes still I
don't have to do it I don't have to play
Bishop f3 I can do whatever yeah the
Queen to a good square and I mean he is
really out of moves in some way okay so
we should bury me and now I mean you
should never never ever ever ever get to
what he go on god I mean I have to play
rupee head and make sure that he does
not castle and I'm 94 on whatever this
song I just have to check him first
and now he gets Bishop e3 in and not
before but also better and now this is
kind of a position 94 I didn't see 94
2045 but okay I'm in this and now this
isn't even anything doesn't even
anything it was already pretty pretty in
no idea yeah if the F Jake's is best
actually threatening both rook f1 and
Roxy 7 so something like that and now
yeah maybe it is equal which
like this yeah I have some counterplay I
mean but yeah it really is totally
unnecessary
yeah and now that was pretty good ending
again
okay g54 stronger Miriam and because I
have h5 of course M that is a lot
stronger
oh sorry that was not intended so I know
is he has to go G for problem then G to
G for was better and th for widest even
better my godness I really have to take
a break after this it wasn't even the
best move I just take it okay make sense
[Music]
this wasn't all so it wasn't super easy
and under the friggin F horn its it so
wins it look takes B to as much easier
[Music]
and now I had G to
jeetu and then promoting yeah I do
promote because here I have this this
thing that was really bad
I mean had three nekaris nine mistakes
to blunder self I mean I managed stuff
like like zero like one zero zero and
good day seven this is just totally
terrible yeah look f7 white is better I
don't know
yeah the the depth is not enough to
totally reliably evaluate what was going
on
[Music]
no one promoters probably was bad I
really have to take a break thanks for
watching this game